[Music]
I'm a big boxing fan was a Mike Tyson
guy growing up loved Tommy Morrison too
bad what happened to him Roy Jones Jr
was my guy light heavyweight champ but
the fastest hands ever
I wasted way too much money buying May
weather pay-per-views though
I love the trash talk that's what got
all the drama going
I want all of America I want the whole
world to see me destroy this man after
two short rounds because after this
fight he's gonna have to donate what's
going to be left of his body to science
but there won't be much that I can
guarantee boxing and politics is a lot
alike they're Jabs where one guy's kind
of feeling the other one out sometimes
you see guys come back off the mat and
win sometimes they're talking trash in
the ring
and in the first round of the 2024
Republican primary we saw Trump test
desantis's defense jab here jab there
see what gets through get his distance
down and now we're in round two and
DeSantis is starting to let his hands go
a little watch
which is your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving you so far is it Ron
Ronda sanctimonious or meatball rock
well I can't even he went off meatball
wrong I can't uh I don't know how to
spell the sanctimonious I don't really
know what it means but I you know I kind
of like it's long it's got a lot of
valve I mean so we go with that that's
fine you know you can call me and you
can call me whatever you want I mean
just as long as you you know also call
me a winner that sounds like a line that
Sanders has been working on good line
good line
DeSantis for the most part it's been
quiet he's been dancing around the ring
doing his thing but DeSantis has found
something that he thinks he can use it's
the term winner
Trump's whole career has been about
winning Trump puts winning above
everything winning is the Trump brand
now DeSantis is saying you lost it's my
brand now
I think you could beat bud I think so
you're running them no I didn't say that
I just said I think I could I mean I
think that that's I mean if you look at
Florida it would be harder to beat Biden
or Donald Trump workout I don't know
Ron's definitely running and these guys
are on a collision course and Pierce
Morgan has a little Don King in them
because he teed up to Santas heavily
people have been quite kind of scathing
they've said you're house trained Donald
your diet coke to his full Coke right
you've heard all this stuff what are the
differences between you well I mean I
think there's a few things I mean
obviously you know the approach to covid
was different I mean you know I would
have fired somebody like fauci I think
that he got way too big for his britches
and I think he did a lot of damage
fauci's going to be a big issue in the
Republican primary and DeSantis is
trying to get to the right of trump on
covet Trump's going to have to defend
the fauci situation the initial 15 days
to slow the spread and remember the
vaccines ended up being controversial
that we checked and to fire someone like
fauci a civil servant is not like firing
your defense secretary you can do that
in a meeting you have to build a case a
whole process that would have taken
months not saying Trump shouldn't have
fired fauci I'm just telling you the
facts
now Trump just came out with an answer
on the covet issue releasing a statement
in part reading this
Rhonda sanctimonius is finally admitting
he's in the race by beginning to fight
back now that his polls have crashed and
he has no other choice Florida has been
successful for many years long before I
put Ron there it's amazing what ocean
and sunshine will do surprise Ron was a
big lockdown governor on the China virus
sealing all beaches and everything else
for an extended period of time Florida
was the third worst in the nation for
covid-19 deaths other Governors did much
better than Ron because I allowed them
this freedom and never close their
states
so those two are going to be duking it
out over covid policy for a while but
DeSantis didn't stop there he hammered
the theme I'm no drama Ron
I also think just in terms of my
approach to leadership you know I get
Personnel in the government who have the
agenda of the people and share our
agenda if you bring your own agenda in
you're gone we're just not going to have
that so the way we run the government I
think is no daily drama focus on the big
picture and put points on the board and
I think that that's something that's
very important
some Republican voters got tired of the
Trump show there was Personnel drama in
the Trump Administration for a lot of
reasons and DeSantis is betting on Trump
fatigue with those people you never know
how that's going to shake out because
Americans love drama it just becomes a
problem when it gets in the way of
governing Trump has to promise little
staff the White House better next time
DeSantis is going to capitalize on the
competence Factor who's a better boss
Ron's going to say I know who to hire I
know who to fire I build a better team
again that goes directly at Trump's
brand the businessman but these aren't
really big policy squabbles this is all
about tone and management right so these
two pretty much agree on most policies
which is why this is getting personal so
fast
these guys will get their most traction
with policy fights maybe more boring but
more important
let's take a look at the polls Trump's
been really climbing in the polls lately
this Monmouth poll from this week shows
Trump up
41-27 on DeSantis now same poll pretty
much flipped just from three months back
Trump was at 26 and Ron was at 40.
that's a big reversal
now another poll this week shows Trump's
up 54-26 doubling to Santa's support
so momentum's on Trump's side right now
but it's early
a lot of Republicans are rallying to the
flag as the Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg
looks to indict the former president
this is bigger than politics Republicans
know this isn't just an attack on Trump
this is an attack on all of us
and DeSantis is in a kind of a tight
spot here
you also repeated twice you didn't have
any knowledge of hush money being paid
to Pawn Stars
was I right to
feel that there was a slightly
sensorious tone to that that kind of
thing is just not anything you would
ever get involved with well I think it's
there's a lot of speculation about what
the underlying conduct is that is
purported to be it and yeah the reality
is that's just outside my wheelhouse I
mean that's just not something that I
can speak to DeSantis is making a
calculation he knows big donors are
going to get skittish about backing a
guy who's been booked and fingerprinted
and Corporate America won't like to
associate with a guy facing prison time
so DeSantis doesn't want to associate
himself with any of that and is waiting
for it to play out to his benefit now
the risk is this
Trump's going to paint you as a donor
puppet
let me talk quiet a lot of times
that's all of his donors and special
interests so
by the way let me just tell you we
needed tickets you can't get them you
know who has the tickets donors special
interests the people that are putting up
the money
the RNC told us we have all donors in
the audience and the reason they're not
loving me
[Music]
isn't they're not loving me as I don't
out of their money
DeSantis Lane is different than Jeb
Bush's Lane though he has a wider Lane
and he's younger than Trump and has a
big career ahead of him but he has to be
careful here and remember Trump's a
billionaire and he's got tons of earned
media attention that can Harvest a lot
of money so DeSantis doesn't have that
kind of money and can't get the same
amount of attention
negative attention positive attention
Trump gets a lot of attention
but he'll be able to raise a lot of
money from big donors maybe even more
from Corporate America but DeSantis
isn't some chill for corporate interests
either you see what he's done with
Disney so this is going to be a
competitive primary Trump's still the
big dog and the first debate will tell
us a lot if DeSantis has enough punching
power to take the throne
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else